viren sind verwandlungskünstler sie
mutieren und verändern sich ständig denn
sie wollen überleben und dafür brauchen
sie zählen egal ob von tieren pflanzen
oder in menschen
das gefährliche daran antibiotika sind
wirkungslos
es kommt allein auf das immunsystem an
mensch gegen das virus
jüngster fall 31 dezember 2009 10
erste meldungen über einen virus
ausbruch in der chinesischen
millionenstadt wo hand tritt plötzlich
und vermehrt eine unbekannte
lungenkrankheit auf ein corona virus
neuen typs ist der auslöser die quelle
möglicherweise eine schlange oder eine
fledermaus ist eine person infiziert
kann sie mit jedem husten mit jedem
müssen millionen neuer viren in die luft
schleudern viren die nur darauf warten
neue zellen zu befallen
besonders gefährdet sind alte und kranke
menschen mit einem schwachen immunsystem
das tückische bereits vor den ersten
symptomen ist der mensch ansteckend eine
mögliche epidemie beginnt heißt eine
infektionskrankheit tritt stark gehäuft
in einer begrenzten region auf bleibt
das virus nicht in einer region sondern
breitet sich in vielen ländern
beziehungsweise kontinenten aus spricht
man von einer pandemie
sie ist die höchste stufe mit der die
weltgesundheitsorganisation das risiko
der viren verbreitung einschätzt
schützen kann man sich mit hygienischen
maßnahmen die regelmäßig hände waschen
und mundschutz
der effektivste schutz ist eine impfung
doch die entwicklung des passenden
stoffs dauert oft monate